foreign
at this point the Revolutionary new AI
based chatbot developed by openai has
taken the World by storm
thanks to its near lifelike responses
and a very intricate pattern of answers
we have never seen this level of
expertise from a chatbot before which
really made us think to what extent can
we push it there are many questions on
lead code that even the most experienced
programmers have difficulty answering so
we wanted to see how far charge GPD can
take us hobby finally reached the stage
where AI is going to replace us let's
find out so basically here we will be
listing 10 really difficult questions
that we found on lead code popularly
asked while hiring and other Superior
examinations and see if chat GPD can
actually answer or solve those difficult
questions or not but before you like to
watch more such interesting videos then
do subscribe to our YouTube channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn so let's get
started so here is the lead code let's
see uh in our list which is the first
question that we are going to implement
in our chat GPD and see if it's able to
solve it or not
mainly we'll focus on hard category
questions only so
according to my research there's a
question of median
of two sorted arrays
so as you can see the success rate is
35.7 percent so let's see the charge
Equity is able to do this question so
first let us go through the question
okay
press enter let's see what it first
returns
uh on a one approach to solving this
problem is to use a modified binary
search algorithm to find the median of
the two sorted arrays so right now it's
particularly giving the logic which we
can actually imply to solve this
question
and this is a good for the charge GPD is
that before uh giving the code it's
actually explaining how they had putting
the logic in together in the code
so probably you can use this logic to
create your own program but let's see
how sensible this code is
quite a learning program
is in Python so if you are looking for
your Solutions on chat GPD you can
always opt out or you know mention the
specific program you want the code in
so okay it's it's also gives that okay
that the time complexity will be o log
Min m or n so let's see if it
the case or not
so we have copied it
and we quickly paste it over here
as you can see
uh as we know that python is uh very
sensitive towards its uh
syntax and you can see the indentation
over here is perfect but here it's not
so I feel that something like this is
something with lead code
so let me just quickly Rectify this so
you can see I have cleared out the
indentation issue and let's just quickly
run this program so that we can get an
idea if this is the correct program
uh now you can see here we have an error
let's see copy this and see what chart
GPD has to say for this
so if you remember when we actually saw
this question there were three arguments
passed through this function which was
self nums 1 and nums two ask GPT if it
can write the code with self-argument
and see if it's correct
and wait that if it can pass a
self-argument through that function and
see if it can generate a new code
okay now it has cleared that yes it
takes three arguments
let's
copy this code
that over here again I think we will
have to go through the indentation
process
oh no this time it's fine okay so now
quickly run this program let's see if
this time it passes all the test cases
or not
okay
I think it doesn't needs because the
class is already mentioned over here
uh
yeah
okay the run time is 35 Ms and as we can
see case 1 and case two is definitely
passed
so
let us see if
this code can pass all the test cases
internally mentioned in this question
now you can see the first three cases
are actually accepted but the other
three are not there's a runtime error
so
the first question in our list chat GPT
was unable to solve let's move on to our
next question
that is zigzag conversion
now let me quickly search for it
this is a question here also you can see
the success rate is definitely below 50
and the difficulty level is medium so
the Hard One charging Beauty was not
able to solve let's see if this can be
done
so it will give a string that will be
written in a zigzag pattern on a given
number of rows
and then you have to read the line in a
certain
as you can see over here
we have to write the code that will take
a string and make this conversion given
in a number of row
has also means a certain amount of
certificate uh repeat that's also given
a certain specifications that we exactly
want so this time we'll make sure that
we are mentioning everything
so let's quickly copy this
okay now that we have mentioned about
the specifications
uh let me quickly
feet
and paste it now let's see what code it
has to generate
it's implementing the code in C plus
plus so meanwhile it's generating the
code let's quickly
select the code oh it's already C plus
plus okay
okay it's also suggesting that we can
definitely use Python and Java
and it's generating an alternative code
as well for us
that's Sharp
oh
just quickly copy this code
[Music]
we
the one I think it's a okay so it's
generating in
Java
let's generating we'll definitely have a
look at its alternative codes as well
let's quickly have a look at what it has
to C plus plus one the first code
generated by it
uh is correct or not
case copy the code
paste it over here
dilation Arrow
okay okay
28 okay
so let's do this later
the one thing but definitely this time
we have mentioned all the constraints
criteria specifications that we wanted
in a code but again
charging
questions we have implemented till now
let's see if it has any success rate in
further
okay it seems okay
now it is okay so this time it is uh
generating the solution
considering the error in Java
uh see what it has to say in Java and
we'll make it specific that the error
was in C plus plus program so generates
the correct code
plus plus program
what it has to say
oh this thing is
let's see so this error is something
related to the compiler and now it is
giving the updated code in C plus plus
is the correct one or not
apologizing for making errors in their
Solutions
quite fascinating
[Music]
um
paste the code over here I don't see
there's a lot of difference or changes
over here let's see if it runs or not
let me see if all the braces are covered
over here or not
I think it's missing a brace
good
okay so there was a syntax error one
brace was missing
um I don't
want that
definitely something with the code but
okay we can give that to charge GPT it
was partially read quotes issue because
we were copying still it was not giving
the error that there is a brace missing
has passed the first three cases
mentioned over here and the run time is
3M is now just let us submit this code
and see if it passes all the rest of the
cases or not minded this time we have
actually mentioned all the constraints
so let's see if this has to in two
okay so this time it has passed all the
test cases but still my conclusion with
this question is
uh it was still not able to generate the
solution in one go
uh but so I can give that to charge GPT
because the first error that we faced
was more of a lead code this issue
because it was something with company
and charge gbt was able to give a proper
oh now let's go back to our problems
list
so right now the score is one and one it
was unable to solve one question and one
not
so let's have a look at the third
question and see if that brings any
difference to the charge equities
scoreboard right now or not
third question that we are going to deal
with is substring
with
concatenation of all words
this is in the category again and the
success success rate is 31.1 percent
which is even lesser than the first
question that we faced which was median
of the two sorted Aries
we dying here we are actually trying to
cover all the Spectra the huge Spectra
of different types of
questions and you know categories
available in coding and to give you an
idea of how
beneficial charging can be for you to
solve difficult questions which can be
helpful for your interview base in
companies or you can say well
established companies among companies
so here this video is specifically for
you to give an idea that whether you can
use it for your benefit and you know to
get an idea or you can actually
compare it with
your
subjects uh and you can get a you know
wider range of different types of
approaches to a certain question
so let's start with the third question
is that you're given a string and an
array of strings probably words and all
the strings or words are of the same
length now a concatenated substring in s
is a substring that contains all the
strings of any permutation of words
concatenated
here you can see it's given an example
that if words has a b c d e f then a b c
d e f basically uh has done all the
permutation and combinations that can be
done using that
specific array
uh
a c d b e f is not a concatenated
substring because it is not the
concatenation of any permutation of
words
so we have to basically return the
starting indices of all the concatenated
substring in the S string
also you can choose any order for it
here it has also given a
two examples for you to
understand the question in a better
perspective
now
really uh copy this question and see if
what programming language algebra
chooses to answer this time
but with no chat again
or be these constraints
okay it's just a question
okay
this is the solution that we're getting
right now you requested a model that is
not compatible with this engine please
contact us through our help center at
help
dot openai.com for further questions let
me just quickly refresh it if it has a
something to do with the you know demand
also sometimes it happens that the
console is very busy and you're unable
to implement
uh your task in it so again let's
quickly
paste it over here
that we want the code the right code
return now
press enter
same definitely it's not giving the same
error
let's see it this time at charger PD has
anything to give as a solution
okay so it's generating the code in
Python
the more thing every time chargeability
doesn't follows a similar pattern as you
can see in the first question it
explained the logic first and then
implemented the code second time it just
gave you the approach not the logic and
then implemented the code in multiple
languages uh first choosing for C plus
plus
and this time it straight away wind for
the gold so definitely we can say that
it has some different styles of
generating their code and explaining the
code I think it depends on the
understanding how they want the code to
be presented in front of the user and to
give the perspective that if the code is
understandable or not and if the code
has multiple approaches I think charge
if it is capable to capable enough to
give that
that the code is generated let's quickly
copy it
and
paste it over here
I feel the indentation issue is going to
be there
but it was not there okay
F probably I think if we backspeed
sure let me quickly Rectify this and
I'll
do once the indentations are
well
the indentation is projected now let's
have a look
at the Gold if it's correct or not let's
quickly run it
definitely it has a given our first
syntax error again
I can see that even a specific video
question it definitely goes to at least
one error which is mainly the syntax one
sure if that is something with the lead
code or you know with the
generation
okay
now that we have given the error okay it
seems that the error is caused by the
use of type hints the function type ends
were introduced the version we are using
is lower than that okay so basically
it's generating now in the python
version uh probably this code is
well suited for different version of
python let's change it then and see if
that helps
knit
is actually generating the code
okay again
the other one I think it's again
something with the self
uh
python one the new code generated is
here
will definitely come back to that error
and have a look at the Python 3 code
also
uh first let's copy this code
and
in giving the same error
and see what it has to say
uh you know every time the charge APD
generates the python code we cannot
ever takes self as an argument but
believe that
as you can see when we start the code
it's already mentioned what arguments we
need to pass from
a particular function so I think that is
something with the lead code so
that what all arguments it's passing
even though we have mentioned everything
this time we have mentioned over the
constraints we have mentioned all the uh
necessary
specifications that we want in the code
even then the code is not correct in the
one go so probably I'll get this point
to GPT it's something with the lead code
because it's passing that parameter and
everything we have to mention that
parameter pretty much when we do the
chargeability is able to solve the
question so let's see let me actually
mention that
because self parameter self argument
from that parameters I'm gonna make it
one of the parameters
processing that
I guess self can be passed as the first
argument to the given function now let's
see if that it's able to give the
correct solution or not again we can see
it's uh generating the code and you know
Python 3
but we can give that to charge GPD that
either it uses python or Python 3 the
error is with the self argument
so once we mention that error and when
we mentioned that specification that if
charge GPD can pass self-argument
through that particular function in that
code
the solution is pretty much
right so here it's also implementing and
giving
the answer
okay it also has mentioned that it's
important to mention import important
list and Contour so
okay
just copy this because again there will
be a lot of uh inpatient issues
okay now that we have it
copy the code
because already mentioned so yeah we'll
just
copy it from the function
paste it
let's run this code and see if it has
the solution in it or not
yeah there is an indentation issue
let me
again as you can see it is able to pass
all the test cases here and the runtime
is 28 MS
now let us submit this question and see
if it is able to pass other test cases
or not
accepted
so it is able to pass all the test cases
and I think this is something with lead
code again uh whenever we are generating
the python code we are actually passing
self argument uh in lead code but charge
GPD is not assuming it so this solution
is definitely correct
uh even though we are specifying
everything we will have to be more
specific that we have to run one more
argument uh from the function so that it
you know generates the solution in one
go so let us uh try that in our next
question
but we can definitely see charge APD was
able to solve this so now the scoreboard
is two one one uh among three questions
it is definitely able to solve two
questions even the first question it was
able to generate a correct solution but
it was not that accurate to pass all the
test cases
to a question list
the next question that we are going to
cover is in Queens
category but still the success rate is
63 over here again a new genre or
question we are covering over here let
us see it foreign
shows that many people were able to do
it definitely more than half of people
who have attempted it so see if the
question can
this AI can beat that or not
so I have to copy this question this
question mentions that the end Queens
puzzle is the problem of placing n
Queens on an N into N Chess board such
that Noto Queens attack each other given
an integer n return all distinct
solutions to the end Queen puzzle
so basically n is any given number and
you have to create a puzzle of end in
and you have to arrange all the Queens
in such uh you know way also the number
of Queens in the board will be equal to
the number
in and in such a way that it is not able
to attack each other in any case
puppet this part of the question
and the constraint is
just one let me
that it would be easy to keep a track of
what all questions charging beauty is
able to solve
so these questions are very popular uh
in interviews uh whenever you actually
go to technical rounds and for
prestigious companies these questions
are very popular
they are considered as very suitable
questions to check to check your you
know IQ and to check your potential that
how well aware you are towards your
coding potential
now we have pressed enter it is giving
the logic it is going to implement in
its code one approach to solve the end
Queens puzzle is to use backtracking
ideas to start by placing a queen in the
First Column of the first row so let's
see if the codes
again capable to you know
solve it or not
again it's giving the python code
generating the code let us quickly see
whether it's python or Python 3
I can python tree
okay
once the code is generated I'll also
write that you need to pass one more
argument from the main function
uh that is self and let let it generate
the code again and see that code can run
in one go or not
should what I want and let the C sure
here's an example of how you can pass an
additional parameter self let's see if
it suits
the code or not
so the 12 and queen function is a method
of the end Queens class and it takes
self as its first parameter followed by
the integer n so yes this solution does
take self as a parameter so let's see if
this can
run in one go or not because this time
we've already covered the most uh
frequently generated error which is
syntax error of not mentioning parameter
self
let me see the indentation if it's
correct or not
this time uh let us quickly run this
class
okay there you go now you can see that
it has actually run the code in one go
and all the test cases are passed in one
go even the runtime is 39 Ms so
definitely charge gbt is able to provide
the solutions the Logics in a proper
manner it's just that we have to be more
specific with what we want exactly from
chat GPT right now we can see that it
has been able to successfully generate
4.5 questions that we have actually
implemented till now out of which four
are from hard category
let us submit this code and see if it
also covers all the test cases
internally fed in for this question just
a second I think I will have to submit
it again
it has accepted all the test cases and
this question is done by child GPT it
has actually implemented
this question that we are going to cover
till now I can say charge gbd has taken
the lead it is pretty much able to
implement all the questions uh I think
there are still some range of questions
that it is not able to implement as we
saw the first one was not a huge success
but
um I can still give that to charge upd
as it is in Ai and still in a you know
developing mode but still if it can give
you 90 of the output correct it is a
pretty decent and you know amazing thing
to do
Shin is shortest sabare with some at
least K now let me search
for it
again this question is from hard
category and its success rate is even
low which is 26.1 let's see if this
question can be solved by chart GPT
let's have a look at the question given
an integer ad in nums and an integer K
return the length of the shortest non
empty sub array of nums with the sum of
at least K so if there is no such sub
array return minus 1.
so
the body is a contagious part of an
array it has also given a description of
what an array is or what sub array is
so now that we have
written a new chat
and let me
explains
so here is one way to solve the problem
initialize two pointers uh left and
right both pointing to the first element
of the array initialize a variable so
now this time this it is giving pointers
to solve this question uh you know a
perfect approach in a sequential manner
so that you can also use these pointers
and the Logics it's giving to actually
Implement your own code apart from you
know asking it to generate a code
so I can see that it has given the
pointers but not the code
specific
so yes uh it's giving an implementation
of the algorithm in Python uh again we
can see it's not the Python 3 it's
python uh little lower version of python
um
which do
python
then we have to pass self
so it has generated code and explain
what all variables and what will
statements have the individual
functionality as so we have also asked
it to pass self parameter through its
function and then write the code so
let's see if it adheres to it and
generates new code with self parameter
okay so here
is the new code with self parameter
passed through the main function
now I do have confidence on chat GPT
that it was able to generate logical and
you know
pretty much decent solutions for every
question
the spouse to the class as an argument
when an object is created and is stored
as an instance variable the shortest sub
array takes K as an argument which is
the target sum so basically it's trying
to explain the code at what exactly it's
doing and what individual statements
have as an influence on the code
and whatever parameters they are passing
what influence or what position they
hold in the code
so definitely charge APD is not just
generating the code uh you know it's
also explaining the logic and approaches
towards it
and when it's generating the code as you
can see here they have legit explain the
whole code how it's actually functioning
that's a good way to you know put
emphasis on you know put a confidence on
the solution
remove this
type error okay
so it's apologizing it made a mistake in
its previous response the init method
should take two arguments one for the
nums array and one for key
so now it's again generating a new code
or adhering to the syntax error or type
error generated like
correct or not
you mentioned that here direct weather
takes two arguments one for the nums
array and one for the K which was the
error exactly
and it's again explaining the whole code
so that one person who watches code or
you know logic could understand the
functionality of it
and say this code can run
food
checking for indentation removing class
and run
this one more type error
let's copy it and
we mentioned that we want self argument
to be passed
it is still not able to generate
you know the correct solution twice
so let's see this time it can work out
issue though with the code
apologize for the confusion seems that I
misunderstood
that you are trying to call the function
directly without creating an instance of
the class and that
function outside of the class and simply
Call It by passing the parameters click
this okay the code is definitely
generated by itself so definitely I am
not calling any function uh the code I
copied was actually generated by charge
GPD itself so it's contradicting its own
pointers Maybe
but we have copied the question uh sorry
the code
let's paste it
again look for indentation
and run this code
okay once again it is not able to you
know
us
I am error is there and now again we
have to copy this error and paste it
again according to chart GPD it was
confused with the context of the
question
uh like I said the code was anyway
generated by Char GPT so yeah
this time I think GPT is trying to
contradict its own logics
let's see if the current code can do the
miracle of solving this question
last
and run
okay so after four attempts of running
the goals generated by charge GPD on
delete code but this particular question
finally now it's able to pass all the
test cases so
I can I have a very contradicting point
right now uh
not exactly contradicting more of a
skepticism that okay Chad gypri does
generate a proper code or logic but it
doesn't considers all the criterias or
it also has a tendency of taking the
question in a wrong context
so I feel that when we as a human try to
solve these questions we definitely try
to implement all the Logics and if we
get it we can actually get the code in
one go
check or you know demand of the question
and be AI being Superior version or you
know trying to be the superior version
of human brain and going to the extents
of a human brain
still faces those issues
can be a you know drawback for chat GPT
because you can see for this specific
question we have faced multiple types of
error and we have seen charge a pretty
contradicting its own prior code
so
definitely this is something to consider
or you know something to think about
submit this code
and have like I said after giving four
attempts it is still not able to pass
all the test cases it is only able to
six pass 61 out of 97 test cases
which is almost 70 percent of the test
cases 30k percent of this test cases are
still not passed even though we
mentioned all the constraints we have
mentioned the garments we have mentioned
all the errors that but this particular
code can go through
still
it was not able to generate the proper
code that could go through all the test
cases
so
this was a fail for chart GPT uh at
least till now we have made out this
point that charge GPT is definitely not
able to solve every question
question
clicked array with same average
for it
array with
this is from the category of hard
questions and the success rate is only
25 percent
Let me refresh it and remove this code
now let's have a look at the code what
it demands so you are given an integer
array nums now you should move each
element of nums into one of two arrays e
and B so can B are non-empty and the
average of array a is equal to average
of array B
now return true if it is possible to
achieve that
condition is not justified
so given a note that for an array uh
average array is the sum of all the
elements of array over the length of
array okay so it is giving the lot of
how to actually you know find out the
average of what average is exactly
and also it is given a few examples to
give you how the code needs to be
projected or implemented
paste copy the code and paste it
okay it is possible to achieve this by
checking all the possible subsets of the
nums array and comparing the averages of
the subsets so definitely it has given
you the approach uh the way you can
actually think of solving this question
uh however this approach would have a
Time complexity so it's also giving that
this approach can have a Time complexity
of O to the power n so again it's
suggesting a different approach a more
efficient approach that will be using
dynamic programming now that can be used
to find the subsets with a specific
average and create a 2d array with the
length of I and J which that will be the
length of the two
we have actually given as input and
represents whether or not it is possible
to get a sum of J using the first
foreign
[Music]
so the time complexity of this approach
would be o and S so definite it is not
given a code let me ask for it
not for every question chart GPD is
generating a code it is also mentioning
just and the approaches that we can
actually use uh definitely again we will
have to mention that what we want from
them
as you can see I've mentioned this time
to write a code for it and now it's
generating a new code for it
it's also mentioning comments that what
every snippet of the code is actually
for and what it will do like here you
can see it will fill the 2dr ADP uh DP
stands for dynamic programming this here
it has mentioned initialized the First
Column as true so it is also mentioning
the comments for better idea of you know
understanding the code in a better way
it's also giving the note that this
implementation assumes that the nums are
is non-empty and that the elements of
the nums array are non-negative integers
okay also the above implementation will
return the possible subset that can be
formed by the array to fulfill the given
condition and not Boolean true and false
but that's what we want exactly right
uh still okay let us
this approach is in Python so let's copy
this and
see if this code can run or not
I can clearly see that again it needs to
pass self
uh
parameter
indentation
and
give it a heads up
what I have mentioned what I want
specifically
uh
shown here is an example of how you can
pass the self parameter so now the
current solution will pass self
okay
rate there was an error okay
and it has generated a new code uh
considering the
criteria I just mentioned that I need
self parameter to be passed through the
function can partnership
so I have copied it and let's quickly
paste it over here
uh you know pass
all the cases are not wait uh we need to
remove this
okay it's done now quickly just run this
program
okay so here is uh
error attribute error solution object
has no attribute okay so let me copy it
and paste it over here and see what
charge GPT has to say about this error
okay the error message solution object
has no attribute
uh split array same average suggests
that there is no method named with this
in the solution class so it is likely
that the test case is trying to call
this method but it does not exist in
your implementation anyway that I have
not mentioned this method this was given
by chargeable itself so again we can see
the condition that it is contradicting
its own so again it has generated new
response and it says that it should
resolve the issue and the test case
should be able to call this particular
method correctly
so that is something for us to decide
now let us copy this code and see that
now is it able to run or not and pass
all these test cases or not
and click on run
okay now the new generated response it
does works for this particular question
and the runtime is 12 Ms and it
trespasses the first two cases mentioned
so let us quickly submit this code and
see if the code is perfectly you know
fine to deal with all the test cases
actually fed by lead code
okay now again we can see one more
situation that this code is not able to
pass all the test cases even though we
mentioned all the specifications
constraints and we were pretty precise
about the questions and parameters that
we want our code to be done in certain
form but still it is just able to pass
68 test cases out of 111 which is almost
50 to 60 percent of uh total amount of
test cases
so let's move on to the next question
that is find substring with given hash
value so let me quickly search for this
question
find substring
with
which value again it's
it's a question from heart category and
the success rate is
22.2 percent so let's have a look at the
question what it demands so here the
hash of a zero indexed string of length
K given integers P and M is computed
using the following functions now hash
with parameters SPM
uh this is the logic given how we want
our output to be demonstrated in certain
value or how the hash can be generated
the particular formula uh how you can
get the hash value of your you know
string
so the question is you are given a
string and then teachers
and you have to return the first
substring of that string of length uh
given to you here it's K the test cases
will be generated such that and answer
always exists we are going to copy this
course and mention all the
specifications mentioned here in their
charging pre console so that it gets
all the specifications
foreign
open the code and
so I have copied the code and I'll paste
it over here now let's check for
indentation it's fine let's remove class
my class
and
again face is a type error so let's move
on to the next question again we saw
that Chachi but he was not able to solve
this particular question coming back to
our list the next question in the list
that we are going to cover is partition
array into two arrays to minimize some
difference let's quickly search for that
question
addition array
to
two arrays
again this question is from hard
category and the success rate is even
more low so let's have a look at the
question first it's partition are into
two arrays to minimize some difference
that is generated as the output
or we can see that there are three
constraints so now quickly we'll copy
this question and see if it is able to
solve this question or not first we have
to create a new
copy
all the constraints
let's see what charging Beauty has to
say for this particular question
let's
ask it to generate a code this time it
has only generated a logic not exactly
Logic the approach indeed they are going
to follow or anyone can follow to solve
this question
let me ask if it can generate a code
be definitely taking longer time to
generate this code okay here is the code
which is possible python implementation
and
[Music]
okay the code is generated and it's
mentioning that the code takes in an
input an array of integer called nums so
basically uh it's explaining that what
it actually is doing which is pretty
much explained in the question itself
that what exactly it needs to function
like and what will be the variables and
what will be the inputs and how it needs
to be segregated to uh obtain our
Optimum result
so
let's copy this
and
paste it over here again like I said we
can see that it's generating you know uh
again we could see that
pass self parameter
okay
attribute error let's quickly copy it
paste it over here
see what chart GPT has to say about it
okay
that you have seen that after placing
the error it's giving that error message
you're seeing suggests that there's a
problem with the function name in your
code so the error message is indicating
that there is no function called minimum
difference within the solution uh also I
have seen that apart from the function
name it doesn't have a self parameter so
let me just write it down
argument
apps let me copy it that will be better
and write the
new code with it
let me see if it can generate a new code
this time
so yeah it has a great show there is an
example and here's the code
I have copied this
and
pasted over
be any such huge difference in the
syntax or the logic of the code
but yeah we can definitely think of
running now
let's run this code
we copy it and paste it over here again
and error has popped out I
don't know how valid
code will get after projecting this
error over here in charge GPD
oh yeah definitely considering the error
message you are seeing is indicated that
the function is returning INF which is
not a valid value for the expected
return type integer
so in the base case where I and J are
both 0 the value of is set to float
which is positively Infinity however the
expected output is an integer so this
valid this value is not valid so again
considering this change the charge
Deputy is giving a new code so let us
see how valid this new code is
okay I can see that it has changed the
logic over here instead of float INF it
has changed it has uh written a new
syntax a new logic over there now and
also chargeable reality guarantees that
this may solve the issue of returning
ilf as the value let's see how accurate
charge GPT here is
now okay we have pasted the logic
as
oh yeah sorry I need to remove these two
lines
now let's quickly run this program
okay so now as you can see it could only
pass one test case
but not the first two so there's no
point of submitting this code as we can
see that the logic for the score or this
code and as a whole is not
well moving on next in the list we have
is
longest common subpar now let's see
longest
common
so this question also comes from
category of hard questions and the
success rate is 27 now let's see what
this question demands actually now let's
quickly copy this question with all the
constraints and what whatever apart from
example is left on the screen we need to
copy it as you can see over here you can
not just miss out on any specifications
talking about the constraints copy
and paste
now enter
giving the approach to solve this
question which is dynamic programming
approach okay we didn't want any code
over here so let's try
that if it can present a code
I guess I have asked to write a code for
this and yes charge GPT has definitely
agreed to provide me a code for it uh
chargeable is done with its explanations
I'll type it out and wait for the new
code which will contain self as a
parameter that it's the score is pretty
similar to the previous one it's just
that it's using the self argument in the
function as it was mentioned by me
so let's quickly copy this code
paste it over here
check for the indentation
we run this code
I should be in yet
okay I spoke too fast here we have
another error let's see what charging
Beauty has to say about this
okay the list index out of range error
is likely occurring
on line 10 because the indices I and J
are being properly bounds checked before
being used to access elements in the
path and TP arrays okay so we have found
a new code let's quickly copy this code
and see if this code is capable of you
know
eliminating the errors we
probably found
click copy and paste
let me check for the rotation
done and run
then we got our error over here even
though after providing so many
specifications and criterias and errors
and conditions yet charging was not able
to provide a perfect solution for the
code
uh moving on to the last question of our
list
that is going to be uh sum of total
strength or Wizards hopefully this
question does from marry for child GPT
and prove itself lucky which rgbt graph
for this video because for now we can
see it's a 50 50 scene uh half of the
question chargible was able to provide
Solutions with and half of the questions
charging Beauty couldn't actually figure
out what
uh needs to be done even the logic and
approach was correct still
implementation of the code was not
correct
so let me search for this
question some of total
strength of wizards again a hard
category question so let's have a look
at the question first
let's copy this question
create a new chat
paste it over here
and
look for constraints now that we have
copied it paste it and enter
he is giving an approach how you can
actually think of a solution for this
particular question chargeability has
not generated any code
uh let me ask for it
okay
so here's an example again they have
implemented the code in Python now it is
also giving a note that the approach is
valid only if you're allowed to modify
the original array and also we are not
working on down over
lunch and and then write this
code so let's see if we can do it with
self argument
okay so yeah there's an example it's
generating the code
okay so let's see
what's the update with the code
here
yes
episode r e
let's add
solution
and run the code
so there's a runtime error let me see
why
okay
this error
and paste it over here
you have to say
the error message solution object has no
attribute mode suggests that there is a
class name solution and the code is
trying to access an attribute named mod
on an instance or that class with
attribute doesn't exist we probably need
to make more specifications and if it
still doesn't works then it clearly
classifies that charge Deputy doesn't
takes every point or a classification uh
you know in consideration which
ultimately
you know reflects on the solution
the new code is here let me quickly
paste it
okay
let's try running this code let's see if
this works
try running it again
it has a runtime error was unable to
solve one more question now that we have
tried and tested a huge spectrum of
questions from lead code on charge GPT
we can conclude that though charge GPD
is an amazing tool with the bright
future it still has its own limitations
and maybe it is not ready to replace
humans or compete with human brains
these questions were picked from a list
of frequently asked questions for
interviews and examinations chart GPT
does have a potential to generate Logics
and approaches for the code in an
effective manner but still its ability
to analyze the question is weak as
compared to humans as we know these
questions are there the success rate
just shows that a proper solution to
exist for these questions but still even
after multiple attempts charging was not
able to find the correct answer but we
can also give charging the benefit of
doubt that it's still it's in its
initial phase and still there are a lot
of aspects that need to be worked on so
probably in future charge GPT can take
an upper hand over this but for now
needs to do a lot of work for these
situations well this was all about this
video If you like this video and found
it interesting and informative please do
like this video and share it with your
peers also if you are able to find a
solution for any of these questions then
do let us know in the comments and if
you have any questions related to this
video then please feel free to ask away
in the comment section our team will
reach out to you as soon as possible
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here